there is a math assignment in
Pennsylvania
this is the math assignment okay I'm
reading this from Snopes by the way so
don't accuse me of misinformation or
disinformation
here's a here's a math question
this is a math question from an
assignment from a math teacher in a
Pennsylvania School
Y equals X plus two
okay that sounds like a math question
3x plus 3y equals 12.
okay now I could probably yeah I could
probably solve that that math question
and then here's the third part of the
math question
Maya Angelou was sexually abused by her
mother's blank at age eight which shaped
her career choices and motivation for
writing a boyfriend a zero two boyfriend
B four six brother C negative three
negative one father
when I saw this they go there are others
another question x equals y minus one y
equals negative four X Plus 21 and then
the third part trying to support her son
as a single mother she Maya Angelou
worked as a pimp prostitute and and then
this is bookie drug dealer nightclub
dancer these are math
questions on a math assignment when I
saw that I said that's fake news there's
no way that's real there's no way that's
just some conservative hoax there's no
no it's real even this Liberal site
Snopes admits that this is true
and they basically just defend it in
January 2017 a high school in the
suburbs of Philadelphia
became the subject of international
headlines after a math teacher gave
students a homework assignment that made
references to sexual assault and
prostitution but they say no it's okay
because it it was just as part of this
series of assignments to celebrate the
Maya Angelou who's this extremely
leftist writer a absolutely terrible
poet I know it's not it's not
politically correct everyone we've all
got to talk about how great Maya Angelou
is she's now taught in a lot of schools
she's a horrible poet she's it's every
second you spend reading Maya Angelou's
crappy poetry would be is it just wasted
you would be much better spent reading a
good poet read some Keats I don't read
read
I don't know Coleridge Shakespeare Dante
don't read Maya Angel it's such a waste
of time and but they defend it and they
all blend it together
and so that even in math class
you have to focus on the
weird life of a radical leftist poet
why do they do that
they do that because kids minds are
plastic and elastic just like those
authors said in in the transgender study
and kids minds are plastic and elastic
and they want to shape them and they
want everything to be about leftist
politics not just in civics class
not just in History Class not even just
in literature class they're doing it in
math class too
that's not some innocent though perhaps
misguided
educational theory that is supposed to
improve no that's a political agenda
being taught in math class this is why
it's so funny when the libs in Florida
say there is no transgenderism being
taught in kindergartens or when the libs
say there is no critical race Theory
being taught in schools of course of
course there is
there's no critical race Theory class no
you're right there's no critical race
Theory class critical race theories in
every class
there is no transgenderism class no
you're right well there sort of is
because there's
sex education comprehensive sex
education in schools which is teaching a
very leftist view of human sexuality but
beyond that it's being taught in every
class
when there's a math problem Johnny
wants to become Jane and he's going 60
miles an hour leaving St Louis you know
I'm using a kind of silly example but
when you read these these actual math
problems from Pennsylvania seems a lot
less silly
glad you liked that clip I am now please
ring the bell subscribe get all the
videos don't miss a single second go to
Apple podcast Spotify Stitcher Google
Play get the audio podcast we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]